there are plenty of ways that filmmakers
and studios curb the content of their
work to appeal to as large an audience
as possible regardless there are still
some theaters that choose not to show
certain films for a variety of reasons
whether they be moral fiscal or
logistical here are just a few examples
of times theaters backed out from
showing a film perhaps the most popular
of the recent films to be refused by a
movie theater is 2017 Star Wars the last
Jedi a small theater in Iowa decided not
to screen this entry in the Star Wars
franchise but not because its owners
objected to the content of the film
instead it was because of an issue with
Disney's terms as part of their
distribution deal Disney required
theaters to screen the last Jedi in
their largest auditoriums for a minimum
of four weeks and took a cut of 65% of
ticket revenue from those screenings
that's a high price to pay for any
small-town movie theater especially in
recent years when plenty of potential
audience members have ditched the big
screen for lots of smaller screens that
stream entertainment at home of course
the last Jedi still went on to grab an
international box office total of more
than 1 billion dollars even without
being shown in the keystone of Northeast
Iowa not all theater cancellations are
the product of intercompany conflict
some are a matter of public safety
the 2014 comedy the interview directed
and produced by Seth Rogen and Evan
Goldberg was the subject of some
headline-grabbing controversy because
its plot is centered around the
assassination of Kim jong-un the current
real-life supreme leader of North Korea
when word got out about the movie's
premise a group of hackers calling
themselves the guardians of peace
threatened that tragedy would befall any
theater that screened the film causing
Rogen and actor James Franco to cancel
publicity appearances haters gonna hate
and aina is gonna ain't that is done an
actual thing people say not long after
this announcement Carmike AMC regal and
Cineplex all stated that they would not
be screening the film citing the safety
of their patrons as their top priority
with so many theaters shutting out the
interview Sony chose to pull its
cinematic release altogether though they
were met with some criticism from then
President Barack Obama for caving in to
terrorist threats in the summer of 2018
in Wisconsin theater company chose not
to screen the Slender Man
because it's violence hit a little too
close to home as many moviegoers
undoubtedly already knew Slenderman is a
fictional character born out of a meme
on the something awful forums in 2009 a
cryptid for the modern world in 2014 two
twelve-year-old Wisconsin girls
allegedly in tribute to this fearsome
fictional being attacked one of their
friends nearly killing her because of
the severity and premeditated nature of
the crime the girls were tried as adults
and charged with first degree attempted
homicide though the victim survived this
horrifying tragedy has surely left its
mark on people from the area the theatre
company chose to withhold the screening
out of respect for the victim and given
the circumstances it's hard to blame
them some film controversies are not as
life-threatening as terrorist attacks
but still managed to keep some movies
out of theaters such as the case of a
drive-in theater in Alabama that refused
to show the live action version of
Disney's Beauty and the Beast after the
director revealed that the character
Lefou Gaston's Lackey is gay the
proprietors of the cinema implied that
homosexuality was inappropriate for all
age audiences and that it was a sin
citing their Christian faith has first
and foremost in their decision-making
process ironically the film also got
complaints from some viewers because
after headlines touted Lefou as Disney's
first openly gay character any Content
that might have dealt with that was
pretty much limited to the subtext it's
basically in every movie
meaning whether or not Lefou can be
considered an example of decent gay
representation it is unfortunate that
this theater chose to discriminate based
on the sexuality of a fictional
character and send a clear message to
their patrons about who they do and do
not approve of in their establishment
perhaps unsurprisingly since this story
was covered by national news outlets the
theater has since changed management's
religious fervor has always been a cause
for controversy in art and media and you
can see a pretty clear example of how
with Monty Python's religious satire
Life of Brian by what name are you
calling him
I've grown we worship you the British
comedy classic is centered on a young
Jewish man who was born on the same day
as Jesus Christ who gets mistaken for
the Messiah and is eventually crucified
and a scene set to a cheerful tune about
looking on the bright side of life
it probably won't shock you to learn
that upon its release in 1979 it was
actually banned in Ireland in Norway
because of its blasphemous themes the
film itself sets out to criticize the
misunderstandings and pitfalls of modern
organized religion rather than
ridiculing faith but the movie still
drew plenty of criticism for its
irreverent treatment of the subject
neither the criticism nor the band
stopped life at Brian from racking up an
outstanding box-office total in the
United States and securing a legacy
among fans a 40th anniversary reissue
saw over 400 screenings across the
United States and United Kingdom a more
serious film that drew inspiration from
Christianity and an even more intense
ire from Christian moviegoers was 1988
The Last Temptation of Christ directed
by the legendary Martin Scorsese this
adaptation of the 1955 novel of the same
name depicts Jesus played by Willem
Dafoe imagining himself entangled in
situations that conflict with certain
biblical depictions of Christ upon its
release an organization called master
media international incited a boycott
which led to coverage on Christian radio
stations protests and eventually three
US theatre companies deciding not to
screen it at all they might have made
the right decision in Paris a screening
of the film was interrupted when a
fundamentalist Catholic group set fire
to the theater while it was playing
injuring 13 patrons
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]